HTML markup is made up of things called tags.
Tags look something like this. The way a tag is
structured is, you've got, a less than symbol, the
tag name, a greater than symbol, the tag contents, which
can actually be other tags or it could just
be text, another less than symbol, a slash, the name,
and a greater than symbol. There's two ways that I
might refer to this. We'd call this the opening tag.
This one, the one with the slash in front of the
name, we call this the closing tag. The names are always
the same, and the only difference is the closing tag has
a slash in front of the name. So you've always got
name, contents, name. Opening tag, contents, closing tag. Now, I'll also
refer to this whole thing as an element. And, you know,
this, this isn't something I'm, I'm really going to quiz you on.
I just want you to, you know, understand that when I'm talking
about HTML I may refer to a tag or I may refer
to the whole thing as the elements, or sometimes I kind of switch the
words a little bit. But, that's what I'm referring to. I'm just
referring to, you know, this structure here. Let's learn about our first tag.